[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur le 7 8 de TV 78
c'est votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines
installez-vous confortablement on parle
ici d'actualité d'info pratique et
d'idées de sortie voici le programme de
ce jeudi 6 avril
la suite de la septième semaine
olympique et paralympique c'est jusqu'à
samedi l'objectif promouvoir la pratique
sportive à l'approche de Paris 2024 avec
un thème cette année celui de
l'inclusion cet après-midi l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
proposa ses étudiants une découverte la
pratique du judo dans un mode inclusif
on vous dit tout dans cette édition il
s'en consomme environ 7,3 kg par an et
par habitant le chocolat et l'une des
gourmandises préférées des Français
forcément l'approche de Pâques les
chocolatiers sont sur le pont comment
font-ils face à cette période va-t-on
payer son chocolat plus cher cette année
en cette période d'inflation quelles
sont les tendances de 2023 l'artisan
chocolatier Olivier roador installé à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et notre invité et
puis comme chaque jeudi nos idées de
sortie pour le week-end un week-end en
plus prolongé avec Pâques nous vous
diront où aller dans le coin pour
chasser vos œufs en chocolat mais pas
que d'autres choses au programme notre
sélection à suivre en deuxième partie
des missions
avec un retour celui de Gabriel bontier
bonsoir Gabriel ça fait un peu plus d'un
mois presque un mois quand vous voyez
plus il était temps de vous revenez
effectivement tout va bien tout va bien
et bien on est très content de vous
retrouver à la présentation des idées de
sortie c'est votre traditionnelle
chronique du jeudi dans le 7 8 week-end
prolongé trois jours il va falloir
s'occuper quel est le menu donnez-nous
un petit avant-goût je vais continuer
sur ce dont vous nous avez parlé en
début de titre les chocolats qui sont là
partout
dans les Yvelines notamment sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais aussi des
lieux emblématiques je pense à France
Miniature le domaine de Madame Elisabeth
il y a plein de choses qui sont
organisées on verra ça dans la deuxième
partie de ce journal mais c'est
décidément l'émission des retours ce
soir puisque après un an et demi
quasiment un an et demi de fermeture
l'Espace Rambouillet va enfin rouvrir
ses portes ce sera demain on en parle
avec vous à Camille saint-get bonsoir
vous êtes responsable développement et
stratégie de va se Rambouillet qui
revient en plus avec un nouvel opérateur
Rambouillet nature on va voir ce que ça
change concrètement et quels sont les
nouveautés au programme de cette
réouverture mais est-ce que tout est
prêt désormais à quelques heures de la
réouverture tout est presque prêt tout
le monde est sur le pont depuis ce matin
dès 5h30 on était à Rungis au marché aux
fleurs pour décorer le parc et donc tout
est en train d'être finalisé encore
alors actuelle et donc en plateau on a
vu aussi des chocolats on se prépare
tous peut-être à manger des chocolats à
l'approche de ce week-end de Pâques
puisque Pâques bien sûr c'est dimanche
Olivier roi d'or est avec nous pour
parler de cette période artisan
chocolatier bonsoir et vous avez donc
votre boutique est installée à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux qui s'appelle
l'atelier roi d'or quelque chose me dit
qu'en ce moment vous avez affaire je
pense oui énormément ouais c'est une
très très très grosse période pour le
chocolat et c'est très très agréable
aussi on aura l'occasion d'en parler
dans dans un instant Régine ralecht en
face de vous est avec nous également en
plateau bonsoir Régine journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 et vous allez dans un
instant nous présenter les informations
du jour ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 6 avril au menu
du jour aussi et des conseils mode
Mélissa sebir vous dira comment savoir
si un vêtement vous va et puis comme
chaque jeudi désormais
alors quoi de beau alors quoi de beau
vous connaissez oui je pense que vous
connaissez vous connaissez peut-être
olive
alors quoi de beau
dans un instant alors c'est notre Mister
météo désormais sur TV 78 Thomas
Fletcher il est spécial mais il est très
sympathique Thomas Fletcher qui vous
donne ses prévisions météo du weekend le
tout de manière décalée et en allant à
la rencontre des yvelinois ce sera à la
fin du 7 8 mais on va commencer
justement par la météo avec vos
prévisions de demain dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
bon il faudra encore attendre avant de
revoir un beau soleil dans le
département c'est nuageux demain sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines il fera 7 degrés
dans les secteurs de Versailles et
Mantes-la-Jolie 8 degrés du côté de
Houdan 6 à Rambouillet et dans
l'après-midi de la pluie devrait se
joindre à la partie mais sait-on jamais
quelques rayons de soleil sont possibles
côté température comptait 13 degrés
partout dans les Yvelines et demain elle
nous fêteront les Jean-Baptiste Le Point
à présent sur les informations du jour à
retenir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Régine rallès et on
commence ces informations du jour avec
cette onzième journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui contre la réforme des
retraites
Grégory au lendemain de la rencontre
entre la première ministre Elisabeth
borne et l'interdical les opposants à la
réforme des retraites continues de ce
mobiliser côté éducation au sein de
l'académie de Versailles c'est près de
10% des professeurs des collèges qui se
sont déclarés grévistes aujourd'hui ils
étaient 12% dans les lycées et 8% dans
les écoles primaires et en ce qui
concerne les pénuries d'essence dans les
Yvelines également on note 26% des
stations essence en pénurie ou en
rupture partielle ou totale et c'est
largement au dessus de la moyenne
nationale qui est de 7% dans les
transports le trafic était quant à lui
quasi normal avec quelques perturbations
notamment sur le RER A et le RER C et
les lignes jlni alors malgré la
contestation la majorité ne compte pas
reculer sur la réforme des retraites je
vous propose d'écouter Mart lévrier
sénateur renaissance des Yvelines quand
on prend le régime des retraites qu'on
dit nous voulons sauver le régime par
répartition sauver le régime partition
s'est sauvé en fait une logique sociale
extraordinaire où il y a une solidarité
intergénérationnelle à travers ce
système on est les seuls au monde où ce
sont les actifs donc les jeunes j'allais
dire pour faire vite qui cotisent et ses
cotisations servent à payer les
retraites de ceux qui sont en retraite
c'est une force extraordinaire mais donc
ça veut dire tout simplement que si on
est dans la logique du système par
répartition auquel tiennent énormément
les Français on doit rester dans le
système et les outils de manœuvre de ce
système sont pas nombreuses il dépendent
de la démographie et en fonction de la
démographie si la démographie tente à
donner de plus en plus
il y a plus beaucoup de possibilités et
c'est un entretien complet à retrouver
dans l'émission entretien politique
présenté par Patrice carmouz alors à
l'une de l'actualité également Régine ça
se poursuit la Semaine Olympique et
paralympique va continuer jusqu'au 8
avril et cette année c'est le thème de
l'inclusion qui est mis en avant tout à
fait il y a cette occasion à des élèves
des neufs cités éducatives des Yvelines
se sont réunis à la salle du Phénix à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes le but de cette
journée faire connaître aux jeunes des
quartiers prioritaires de politiques de
la ville ce que sont les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques ils ont présenté des
spectacles des œuvres artistiques en
présence de Camille Renault qui est
championne Regnault pardon qui est
championne breakdance on écoute tout de
suite les réactions au micro de Michael
elneau de pouvoir partager mon parcours
avec avec les jeunes et j'espère que ça
pourra les motiver ça leur donne
l'occasion de se montrer d'être fier de
et on commence à réussir sa vie par le
bonheur d'être ce qu'on est par de la
fierté d'être ce qu'on a et ça nous
donne beaucoup besoin du coup je suis
vraiment fière d'avoir été là parce que
sinon je serais pas là et je crois que
j'ai devenu je suis devenue fan de
Camille
et jusqu'à la cérémonie d'ouverture en
juin 2024 chaque cité éducative
organisera une journée et invitera une
délégation des autres cités et toujours
à l'occasion de cette semaine olympique
et paralympique l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines organisent des
rencontres et activités sportives entre
les jeunes et des personnes du troisième
âge et cet après-midi à l'Ehpad MGEN la
verrière des jeunes et leurs aînés se
sont réunis pour créer une fresque sur
le thème du partage une première
mondiale ça se passe du côté du
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines un super
ordinateur analyse les performances des
cyclistes sur la piste oui et c'était ce
mercredi 7 avril la Fédération française
de cyclisme a présenté un computer vie
jeune développé par la société Dartfish
son objectif analyser les performances
des athlètes pendant leur entraînement
et les compétitions à l'aide de caméra
de tracking on écoute les propos
recueillis par Mickaël elmie Doro c'est
clairement davantage pour les JO on a
déjà mis en route ça pour les
championnats les derniers championnats
du monde
et donc c'est un vrai avantage
concurrentiel d'être les premiers à
acquérir ce type de données oui
aujourd'hui les athlètes la génération
baigne dans la technologie donc ils
comprennent très très vite et puis ils
ont participé notamment aux échanges au
retour aussi des scientifiques et ils
ont des questions très très pertinentes
auprès aussi auprès des scientifiques et
des chercheurs et on termine ces
actualités avec une information emploi
c'est ça la CAF des Yvelines recrute 38
collaborateurs donc la Caisse des
Allocations Familiales recherchent 30
gestionnaires conseils allocataires pour
accompagner les bénéficiaires dans leur
démarche il y a également huit postes
qui sont ouverts pour accompagner les
parents séparés dans la gestion de leurs
pensions alimentaires merci Régine et si
vous aussi vous voyez une actualité une
information qui vous fait réagir près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
vous l'entendiez l'actualité du jour
c'est bien sûr cette onzième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites avec une impression celle de
se diriger vers une impasse avec un
gouvernement qui ne souhaite pas reculer
sur sa réforme et le de notre côté une
contestation qui continue dans les rues
dans ce contexte quels sont les
conditions pour sortir de la crise
écoutée la vie et l'analyse de la Polito
économiste Véronique Jérôme qui est
aussi maître de conférence à
l'Université Paris Saclay
[Musique]
il est urgent d'éviter les politiques du
pire qui souvent finissent en pire des
politiques face au gouvernement qui
reste convaincu que sa réforme est la
bonne sondage après sondage
manifestation après manifestation la
colère ne redescend pas pour preuve elle
reste en tête dans les enquêtes mais
cette détermination puisée dans la
résignation peut-elle encore durer tous
gouvernement syndicat France qui
manifeste ou France silencieuse tous
souhaite une issue mais chacun voyant
midi à sa porte reste inflexible sur la
question des 64 ans un premier pas une
main tendue ont été risqué sincère ou
stratégique l'invitation de la première
ministre pour ne pas être en reste face
aux propositions de Laurent Berger on
dit que Matignon s'empresse à prendre
son temps comment ne pas voir avant la
rencontre que tous première ministre
comme syndicats savent qu'ils ne vont
patienter dans la salle d'attente
jusqu'à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel l'Inter syndicale pas
accepter de venir pour enterrer la
réforme que l'exécutif entend célébré il
y a là visiblement à malentendu sur le
dress code l'inflexibilité revitalise le
bras de fer jeu de la poule mouillée
dans la littérature économique ou toutes
ces intentions annoncées s'achève en
stratégie fatale le spectre du tous
piégés et perdant d'une réforme passée
dans le fracas d'un 49-3 resurgit un
flexible les français plutôt résignés
pas convaincus car la colère est
toujours là cherchant des coupables il
déjuge les politiques pour une mauvaise
gestion de la crise et retrouve un peu
confiance dans les syndicats et en
partie aussi dans l'opposition à tout le
moins le RN et Nuxe de la nesd réactions
comme autant de politiques du pire car
le constat de coût irrécupérable l'idée
de plus rien à perdre on a tant perdu de
salaire pour les grévistes de force dans
les luttes pour les syndicats il reste
convaincu aussi que le gouvernement ne
prendra pas le risque ça recule
décrédibilisant mais on ne peut laisser
le constat confortant la flexibilité de
tous sans ignorer que ceci conduit à la
pire des politiques pour éviter le pire
il ne faut pas oublier l'économie car
lorsqu'on néglige économie souvent elles
se venge elle a frôlé la récession et
reste fragile les signes encourageant
d'un taux de chômage qui venant de 9 %
tourne autour de 7% et se stabilisera
autour de ce point est encore loin de
l'objectif ambitieux d'un plein emploi à
5%. qui peut affirmer aujourd'hui qu'une
crise financière n'est pas une option le
desserrement d'une politique monétaire
n'est pas en vue c'est une bonne
nouvelle ni pour les investisseurs ni
pour la croissance une décision des
sages validant l'essentiel de la réforme
neutralisera les plus légitimistes CFDT
en tête réactivera des mouvements de
colère plus épars en tout cas de la part
des plus réfractaires en réponse à cette
foule qui gronde d'une colère qui
s'égare dissolution référendum usage de
l'article 10 pour relancer des
délibérations semble vain de la part de
sortant dont le socle électoral est déjà
fragilisé un remaniement est prélissité
dans les sondages avec élargissement de
la majorité à voir nécessaire pour la
poursuite de réforme importante
compliquée avec l'embarras d'une
alliance de LR divisé par exemple il ne
reste donc plus à Emmanuel Macron car
remercier sa première ministre et à
remanier victime d'une usure du pouvoir
précoce elle ne joue plus son rôle de
par avant n’hésitant pas au président de
sembler au terme d'un second mandat à
peine entamé il s'imposera donc le choix
d'un profil plus consensuel acteur d'une
sortie de crise rapide qui permettra
aussi d'éviter l'attentisme et
l'immobilisme des seconds mandats c'est
une question de volonté politique pour
une résilience économique s'engager à
œuvrer en transparence pour une économie
consolidée au service de français mieux
informés et en conséquence plus libre de
faire leur propre choix et peut-être
plus confiant dès lors que le politique
fera sien le conseil de Pythagore
n'entretient pas l'espoir de ce qui ne
peut être espéré
[Musique]
on va à présent prendre la direction de
l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est l'autre
actualité du jour et de cette semaine
avec une semaine olympique paralympique
l'établissement c'est justement mobilisé
pour cet événement on est à un peu moins
de 480 jours de Paris 2024 est-ce que
c'est un événement aussi bien l'Espace
Rambouillet aussi au niveau de la
chocolaterie roi d'or à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux qu'on attend avec
impatience quand on a un événement d'une
telle ampleur qui va se passer juste à
côté de son son établissement c'est
surtout qu'en plus là on a le vélo Drôme
ça va être une voilà ça va être ça va
quand même être je pense ça va remet
beaucoup de monde et puis ça va être
très très sympa parce que voilà nous on
est sur un des sites et je pense que ça
va intéresser tout le monde ça va
impliquer tout le monde
pour créer peut-être des chocolats je
suis déjà à la recherche de dîner et de
comment ça fait
des protos pour voir un peu ce que ça
peut donner et bon on va peut-être
arriver à faire quelque chose de sympa
et puis j'espère que les places seront
pas trop cher pour qu'on puisse aussi
le débat du moment où il y aura la phase
de billets unique qui va s'ouvrir très
prochainement est-ce qu'on espère
profiter de l'élan olympique à l'Espace
Rambouillet évidemment on se réjouit de
pouvoir participer et d'être terre de
jeux avec toutes les Yvelines et de
pouvoir accueillir potentiellement des
athlètes leur famille ou des visiteurs
supplémentaires à l'Espace Rambouillet
pour se détendre et se ressourcer alors
c'est la Semaine Olympique et
paralympique l'UVSQ l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
s'est mobilisé avec aujourd'hui une
démonstration de judo inclusive qui
était au programme avec des judokas
professionnels et le tout sur le campus
de Versailles de l'université avec un
champion de France présent Benjamin
axius sur place on va retrouver tout de
suite nickel et le midoro accompagné de
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
nous sommes le jeudi à 6 avril nous
sommes à lui et faire des sciences ici à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à mes côtés le
professeur Eric azabou qui a organisé
une journée un peu spéciale ici à
l'occasion de la Semaine Olympique sur
le thème de l'inclusion tout à fait ici
à l'université tout un après-midi dédié
au judo dans une modalité inclusive
c'est-à-dire en 10 judo en partenariat
avec la commission Andy judo du comité
78 l'objectif étant de démontrer à faire
des démonstrations de comment se passe
le endi judo et montrer aussi que c'est
possible que toute personne même en
situation de handicap peut pratiquer le
judo et en profiter pour son bien-être
mais également il y a quelques
champignons durant des judo sachant que
le handy judo reste avec le taekwondo
les deux seules disciplines des arts
martiaux à être représenté aux Jeux
paralympiques depuis le judo Jeux
paralympiques depuis 1988 mais c'est
très peu connu d'où l'occasion de
profiter de cette semaine olympique dans
le thème est l'inclusion pour mettre en
lumière cette activité là qui a autant
important pour les personnes en
situation de handicap mais aussi
simplement le judo pour toute personne
est vraiment sur ça de d'émancipation
d'équilibre et c'est beaucoup de valeur
ça va tomber ça va se relever et puis
pour dire simplement aussi que le judo
reste la discipline qui rapporte à la
France le plus de médailles actuellement
quand même
lors de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques alors on le voit derrière
nous il y a des exercices qui sont
proposés par les professeurs de cette
journée qu'est-ce qu'ils vont apprendre
pendant cette journée voilà pendant
cette journée il s'agit vraiment pour
les professeurs de démontrer aux
personnes parfois en situation de
handicap qui pratique déjà le judo
depuis ce moment de montrer de nouvelles
techniques pour être encore plus au
point mais aussi pour les personnes qui
hésitent à s'y engager de voir comment
ça se passe concrètement de voir que
c'est bien possible que tu es en
situation de handicap notamment mental
on peut quand même aussi encore faire du
judo et en tirer profit alors il y a une
cinquantaine de participants derrière
nous d'où ils viennent ces participants
comment ou les avaient sélectionnés
alors c'est participant viennent de la
commission Andy judo 78 une commission
du comité judo des Yvelines qui
s'implique depuis plusieurs années à
structurer l'activité judo des personnes
handicapées ce n'est pas facile mais ils
y arrivent et ils méritent vraiment de
d'être soutenu ils ont quel type de
handicap écoutez on a on a des personnes
qui sont des trisomiques puis on a des
enfants qui sont autistes des enfants et
des moins jeunes aussi et on voit bien
que certains pratiquent le lundi judo
depuis plusieurs années et à dire du
président de la commission du judo
monsieur Jean-Michel sifflet et bien il
a bien vu l'évolution de ses enfants là
au fil des années comment le judo a
permis de se structurer davantage dans
la société merci professeur
Eric azabou et nous allons maintenant
rencontrer un judoka qui donne des cours
cet après-midi
et voilà nous sommes donc maintenant
avec le judoka Benjamin Axus alors
Benjamin qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte
vous de faire ce type d'activité
alors tout d'abord à la base on le fait
pas pour nous on le fait principalement
pour les autres parce qu'on le fait avec
des personnes en situation de handicap
alors après effectivement c'est des
choses qui nous apportent quand même
quand même à nous moi en tant que
personne en tant que sportif c'est vrai
que ça m'apporte pas mal de choses je me
rends compte à quel point les ils sont
courageux et en fait ils mettent une
tellement de positivité dans leur dans
leur sport et dans la pratique du judo
que vraiment ça nous ça nous donne le
sourire et ça nous fait relativiser sur
plein de choses vous leur apprenez des
petites techniques je connaissais pas
ouais on essaie de leur apprendre que ça
soit à prendre à chuter ce qui est
important parce que la vie de tous les
jours on est amené par voie
malheureusement à chuter donc ils
apprennent à savoir chuter pour pas se
faire trop mal ou après on a on les a
pris aussi à faire chuter leur
adversaire dans le vraiment dans les
dans le thème du judo donc c'est bien ça
les ça les sort un peu de leur quotidien
et on leur apprend on leur apprend à
sport qui est vraiment avec des valeurs
importantes et je pense que aujourd'hui
ça montre qu'on est là pour eux et que
eux ils sont vraiment contents d'être là
ils viennent là vraiment pour apprendre
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit que au judo tout le monde peut
participer peu importe son handicap peu
importe les problèmes qui peut avoir
tout le monde peut pratiquer le judo et
c'est ça qui est qui est génial et c'est
moi c'est ce qui m'a vraiment le plus
choqué moi c'est que je m'attendais pas
à CS soit aussi inclusive que ça et
vraiment tout le monde peut participer
tout le monde peut faire du judo
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ça qu'on
essaie de montrer vous leur parler un
petit peu des Jeux olympiques de 2024
j'imagine bah ouais ils savent tous que
voilà moi c'est de la compétition du
coup ils sont à fond derrière moi et
m'envoie plein d'autres positifs donc
dès que dès il y aura une petite
médaille je la ramènerai ici avec
plaisir alors vous êtes yvelinois vous
êtes originaire de Montfort-l'Amaury
est-ce que c'est une saveur particulière
d'être ici dans les Yvelines à
Versailles pour vous bah bien sûr ça
fait toujours plaisir de revenir de
revenir près de chez soi on va dire ça y
est j'ai passé une grande partie de mon
temps quand j'étais jeune donc non ça me
fait très plaisir de venir ici et de le
faire à Versailles donc c'est un plaisir
pour moi de d'être dans les Yvelines ça
compte pour moi en tout cas
[Musique]
cette journée sur l'inclusion se termine
ici à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'autres
opérations de ce type se dérouleront sur
site dans les prochains mois
allez dans le 7 8 c'est l'heure de
sortir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
j-3 avant Pâques une période de
gourmandise pour des millions de
Français en consomme en moyenne par an
et par habitant 7,3 kg de chocolat avec
forcément un pic en ses potes je crois
qu'il y a quelques consommatrices de
chocolat en plateau régime Gabriel que
je me trompe
[Musique]
avec tout ces beaux chocolats sous les
yeux alors sachez tout de même qu'on est
assez loin des Allemands qui consomment
11 kg par an et par habitant de chocolat
c'est une période de roche forcément
Olivier roi d'or je le rappelle vous
êtes artisan chocolatier et installé à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux votre boutique
c'est l'atelier roi d'or c'est une
période charnière pour les chocolatiers
sur cette période que vous allez
réaliser l'essentiel de votre chiffre
d'affaires c'est c'est après Noël la
plus grosse grosse période c'est
beaucoup de travail c'est plus de trois
mois de travail parce qu'il faut déjà
préparer toute la partie
savoir ce qu'on va faire quel les
nouveautés bon ça demande aussi tout au
long de l'année rechercher d'autres
idées d'autres moulages et c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est compliqué parce
qu'on a on a déjà une belle famille mais
il faut l'augmenter il faut amener des
nouveautés il y a peut-être des
nouveautés dont on va parler parce qu'il
y a des traditionnel lapin les œufs on
voit une licorne peut-être dans les
nouveautés mais il faut senser se
réinventer ça représente à peu près
combien du chiffre d'affaires la période
de Pâques grosso modo c'est 20% de la
partie chocolat sur toute l'année et
donc deuxième période la plus importante
derrière Noël c'est voilà Noël voilà
Noël c'est Noël tout le monde se lâche à
Noël mais à part aussi hein c'est
pas que c'est pour les enfants c'est
pour les adultes c'est pour tout le
monde et voilà on est on essaie d'être
prêt et puis c'est un rush sur un peu de
jours donc il faut qu'on soit
suffisamment nombreux pour servir pour
aider pour mais voilà c'est une passion
ça reste une passion et franchement
c'est c'est un moment incroyable et
voilà on est parti de ma famille
pourquoi on aime tant le chocolat à
votre avis moi je connais quelques
personnes c'est très rare j'en connais
qui n'aiment pas le chocolat mais
pourquoi on aime tant de chocolat
déjà enfin le chocolat ça associe
particuliers c'est que d'abord c'est un
côté visuel ensuite c'est un côté
olfactif c'est à dire qu'on arrive voilà
ça sent le chocolat c'est vous devez
vous en apercevoir et puis la troisième
des choses après c'est un côté gustatif
c'est une surprise c'est un moment qu'on
attend c'est une fois par an et voilà
tout le monde attend ça on cache les
œufs on faisait c'est un moment familial
c'est un moment festif et je pense que
c'est pour ça que c'est que ça plaît à
autant de personnes on peut en trouver
partout en grande surface dans des
chocolats qu'est-ce qui différencie le
bon chocolat du mauvais chocolat
qu'est-ce qu'il y a à faire que ça soit
que ce soit un bon chocolat
un bon chocolat c'est un chocolat dans
lequel on va pas rajouter de sucre par
exemple où on va pas rajouter de matière
grasse autre que la matière grasse du
cacao
c'est principalement c'est le fait
d'utiliser des bonnes matières premières
et surtout pas faire de rajouter à cette
sucre dans le chocolat mais rajouter du
sucre ben ça veut dire qu'on va mettre
moins de la partie noble c'est-à-dire
moins de bon chocolat et voilà comme on
arrive à transformer un produit où on
utilise des matières grasses puisqu'elle
a la digestation a changé et on peut
utiliser n'importe quoi comme matière
grasse voilà après c'est un choix que ça
dépend aussi des goût des gens on est
plutôt chocolat au lait chocolat noir
aussi ça c'est à part ça c'est à part en
fait la qualité là on parle des matières
premières des bonnes matières premières
ça fait des bons produits c'est toujours
la règle Gabriel vous avez une question
oui justement en parlant de qualité
comment on conserve son chocolat pour le
de tenir le plus longtemps possible
alors faut le garder à température
ambiante voilà et puis surtout pas de
frigo parce qu'après il va en fait il va
blanchir c'est-à-dire que la matière
grasse ça va ressortir du chocolat et ça
va faire des traces blanches
donc on va dénaturer un peu le goût du
chocolat donc si vous restez dans son
équilibre bah comme là ici c'est parfait
on est prêt le déguster et donc faut le
manger dans les deux trois semaines qui
suivent et vous parliez des matières
premières il y a eu un contexte
particulier on est toujours dedans c'est
ce contexte d'inflation avec une hausse
aussi du coup des matières premières à
quel point vous êtes impacté vous à la
chocolaterie chocolaterie le prix du
chocolat il a doublé donc c'est à dire
que cette année on paye son chocolat
plus cher un peu mais forcément on peut
on peut pas comment dirais-je faire
supporter aux clients l'impact des
évolutions des matières premières dans
des proportions si aussi importantes on
fait le pari c'est que les choses vont
redevenir raisonnables donc oui ça a
augmenté mais de façon extrêmement
modeste de façon à ce que ça reste un
produit abordable et puis c'est voilà le
chocolat ça reste le chocolat donc s'il
y a toujours du succès il y a toujours
des consommateurs malgré le contexte
d'inflation qui viennent en nombre dans
votre boutique
oui oui oui parce qu'ils savent que chez
nous il y a un choix il y a des
personnages il y a c'est c'est large de
Noé la boutique et
je pense que c'est toujours aussi bon
enfin je l'espère que j'espère que c'est
perçu comme ça et puis voyez ça fait
envie en tout cas oui ça fait envie ça
sent bon ça fait envie vous disiez le
plaisir olfactive gustatif et le plaisir
des yeux aussi oui elle bon chocolat il
va donner toute façon il a une odeur que
que moi le chocolat dans lequel on va
mettre énormément de sucre parce que ça
conserve et ça coûte pas très cher mais
voilà je pense que vous avez respirer un
petit peu le chocolat donc voilà et
pendant quel pays ce qui est un pays en
particulier sur le cacao le cacao c'est
principalement tous l'équateur d'accord
c'est parce que c'est le comment
s'appelle le cacaoyer en fait il pousse
souvent sous les bananiers c'est un
petit c'est un petit arbre qui est un
peu un peu taquin parce que en fait il
fait beaucoup de fleurs sur toutes ces
fleurs il va y avoir 1% des fleurs qui
vont se transformer en cabosse dans la
cabosse c'est à peu près une à peu près
80 fèves et puis après ben on va lui
faire on va on faire sécher on va les
torréfier comme du comme comment
dirais-je comme du café et puis ensuite
on va écraser on va écraser tout ça et
là on va séparer la partie purement
cacao purement chocolat de la partie
matière grasse et du beurre de cacao et
puis après ben après on va faire le
conchage on va on va rajouter du sucre à
ce moment-là et là puisque ça en fait
partie et puis on va on va sortir du
chocolat brut et donc dans une
chocolaterie comme la mienne on va
utiliser des chocolats d'origine on va
faire des assemblages un peu comme le
champagne pour pour changer les goûts
voilà un petit peu comment se passe le
chocolat c'est voilà c'est un métier
extrêmement envoûtant alors vous êtes
venus avec quelques unes de vos
créations c'est quoi les tendances cette
année là c'est toujours les mêmes alors
il y a deux tendances il y a ceux qui
veulent des chocolats c'est à dire
qu'ils vont acheter des chocolats comme
ça parce que
parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie d'avoir des
sujets et puis il y a tous ceux qui
aiment les sujets alors c'est toujours
la il y a toujours les Mosses ça restera
les œufs
les poules
ça c'est les grands les grands
classiques la licorne aussi qui est bien
joindre à tous cette arche de Noël et
vous parlez d'argent parce que c'est ça
on apporte plein de choses différentes
et puis ça plaît les arches de Noël
après vous avez vous avez Pikachu vous
avez Miaouss vous avez on a fait des
baleines on fait des personnages
japonais on essaie de faire plein de
choses pour qu'il y ait un choix bon
après ça fait beaucoup de choix et très
rapidement si on n'est pas venu encore
acheter son chocolat est-ce qu'on peut
venir au dernier moment qu'est-ce que
vous conseillez jusqu'au dernier moment
vous serez ouvert dimanche matin c'est
ouvert dimanche matin c'est ouvert lundi
toute la journée et voilà on est là pour
on est c'est le moment ou jamais quoi
donc on est à la disposition des gens
vous avez acheté votre chocolat autour
de la table Camille déjà cet après-midi
pas encore mais je vais pas tarder
encore plus mais pareil je il faut que
je me dépêche
c'est une première en tout cas merci
d'être venu en parlant le plateau vous
restez bien sûr avec nous ce qu'on va
continuer de parler de Pâques et de
chocolat dans cette émission parce que
pas que c'est aussi l'occasion vous le
disiez Olivier radar des chasse aux œufs
partir à la recherche des précieux
chocolat beaucoup de villes de City
Blinois organisent leur événement on
fait le point avec vous dans un instant
Gabriel sur l'essentiel du programme à
Maurepas la municipalité a choisi de
prendre les devants avec une chasse aux
œufs qui était organisée et des week-end
dernier on regarde ce reportage de
Mathilde de Franco et de Céline Charles
4 3 2 1 une chasse aux œufs
à peine le top départ de la chasse aux
œufs lancés à Maurepas les enfants
s'éparpille dans le bois de Nogent à la
recherche de milliers de coloris le 2 et
là il faut que tu cherches le rouge
numéro 4 allez allez go
la stratégie pour les tout-petits c'est
simplement des œufs de différentes
couleurs pour les plus grands après
derrière jusqu'à la 11 ans en fin contre
c'est des œufs de différentes couleurs
mais avec des chiffres qui se suivent
deux œufs en or et un en argent ont
aussi été cachés pour plus de chocolat
chacun à sa technique pour les
trouveras
des trucs comme ça en général
on pousse et ce qui est en dessous pour
retrouver la collecte est ensuite
échangée avec de vraies gourmandises
ouais non franchement c'était sympa les
petits œufs à la place il y a des petits
des grands très sympa il y a des œufs en
chocolat monstrueux je pense que là il
va falloir quelques jours pour pouvoir
les déguster et des belles panières des
belles compositions en fin de compte de
nos partenaires un rendez-vous important
pour les morts pasiens pour septième
édition près de 300 petits et grands
explorateurs ont répondu présent c'est
une manière d'occuper les enfants et
c'est une mauvaise manière de se lever
tôt alors qu'on pouvait se reposer
des petits c'est dommage mais j'en fais
depuis qu'on a des petits-enfants oui
c'est super ça fait la deuxième année
qu'on a un œuf en or donc c'est bien
sinon puis c'est sympa ça rien du tout
mort pas c'est sympa les cloches n'ont
pas encore sonné et pourtant les enfants
ont déjà été gâtés un échauffement avant
que le lapin de Pâques ne passe dans
leur jardin et dans d'autres communes
Gabriel ce n'est que le début des chasse
aux œufs oui ce n'est que le début car
qui dit week-end de Pâques dit chasse
aux œufs vous le voyez apparaître sur
votre écran dans les communes des
Yvelines plusieurs sont organisées le 8
avril a Élancourt Coignières ou
Villepreux le 15 avril ce sera au tour
de la ville de trappes de faire sonner
les cloches je vous conseille de vous
rendre sur les sites Internet des
communes pour vous inscrire beaucoup de
possibilités à 50 ans en Yvelines mais
aussi dans le département des lieux
emblématiques qui vont faire leur chasse
aux on va parler dans un son de l'Espace
Rambouillet mais il y a d'autres sites
incontournables faites également Pâques
comme le zoo safari de Thoiry le domaine
de Dampierre le Château de Rambouillet
ou encore la ferme de Gally et le
domaine de Madame Elisabeth pour ne
citer que à noter également que ce
week-end c'est la réouverture de France
Miniature le parc qui lui aussi a prévu
une chasse aux œufs gourmands tout au
long de ce week-end prolongé de Pâques
on va faire le point avec vous dans un
instant sur les autres idées de sortie à
faire ce week-end parce qu'il y a pas
que Pâques mais on va quand même
reparler de Pâques dans un instant
puisque le quiz du jour c'est aussi un
rendez-vous du jeudi portera ce soir sur
la thématique de Pâques une première
idée de sortie justement avant de voir
le reste avec vous Gabriel c'est un
retour dans les Yvelines on en parlant
en début d'édition l'Espace Rambouillet
va rouvrir demain vendredi 7 avril et ce
après quasiment à un an et demi de
fermeture le parc forestier et animalier
avait fermé pour la dernière fois en
novembre 2021 Camille saint-get vous
êtes avec nous pour en parler
responsable développement et stratégie
de l'Espace Rambouillet alors des
nouveautés sont prévus on va en parler
aussi dans un instant une première
nouveauté déjà c'est qu'il y a un
nouveau gestionnaire pour cet espace
Rambouillet que vous représentez c'est
la société Rambouillet nature une
délégation vous a été accordé pendant 30
ans quels sont les objectifs justement
de la société l'objectif de la société
en fait rembourser nature est une
société à mission donc déjà on a
vraiment pour mission de se centrer
autour de la culture et de
l'environnement c'est à dire de la
culture des enfants mais aussi des plus
grands à la biodiversité à la nature à
la forêt et tout ce notre environnement
local avant toute chose et donc c'est ça
notre première mission et aussi tout ce
qui est les actions de conservation de
certaines espèces qui sont plus en
danger il y avait toute une incertitude
autour de cette réouverture du parc
espace Rambouillet c'est important qui
s'appuie rouvrir et en plus cette année
si l'année anniversaire c'est les 50 ans
d'espace 50 ans l'Espace Rambouillet a
été créé il y a 50 ans par un agent ONF
monsieur Kerjean et à la même en plus ou
moins au même moment mon grand-père a eu
la même idée dans l'Est de la France
dans un parc qui est aussi autour de la
faune sauvage européenne et donc l'ONF a
lancé un appel à concession puisqu'ils
avaient quelques difficultés à pouvoir
mener le projet au bout et donc on s'est
porté candidat le processus a duré un
peu plus d'un an et demi mais nous voilà
et on se réjouit on a eu les clés le
premier février et on se réjouit de
pouvoir rouvrir raccueillir du monde et
continuer la belle mission de l'onfs
franchement c'est voilà ça aussi c'est
inoubliable faut y aller faut y
retourner c'est c'est les découvertes
incroyables c'est on a vraiment être
pression d'être dans la nature mais on a
près de soi les les les
oiseaux ils sont ils sont incroyables il
y a aussi des sangliers 200 animaux 150
rapaces le tout sur un espace de 250
hectares en pleine forêt juste pour ceux
qui le connaissent pas en quelques mots
c'est vraiment une rencontre avec la
nature une rencontre avec la forêt qui
est au rendez-vous
c'est c'est la nature la forêt
au final la forêt de protection de
Rambouillet avec les animaux de la faune
locale et également la voilerie la seule
volerie d'Île de France est dans les
Yvelines et avec 150
oiseaux donc c'est quand même assez
impressionnant
des animaux
exactement on a une boue on a des poules
et des lapins aussi qui qui sont arrivés
donc
le chocolat et l'Espace Rambouillet
Gabriel vous aviez une question oui
justement vous avez cité à plein de
choses que les visiteurs connaissent
déjà pour la plupart ce qui sont
habitués est-ce que il y a des nouvelles
choses qui vont être mises en place des
activités en particulier pour la
réouverture il y a plusieurs petites
choses donc déjà ce weekend on organise
aussi une chasse aux États comme tout le
monde on profite de cet événement pour
organiser une chasse aux Etats dans
notre camp du berger donc c'est vraiment
une la forêt du berger avec quelques
animaux de la ferme pour évoquer le
pastoralisme en forêt qui avait lieu en
forêt de Rambouillet et puis on aura un
train électrique qui est arrivé pour
faire une visite guidée de la forêt
sauvage puisque c'est 25 hectares c'est
assez conséquent donc ça permet de
d'avoir un guide avec soi pendant une
heure et puis on a différents projets
aussi qui vont arriver tout au long de
la saison on a un nouveau parcours dans
les arbres qui devrait arriver au mois
de juillet
exactement on a augmenté un petit peu
les différents signalétiques
pédagogiques quelques ateliers de Land
Art pour donner un petit peu de vie au
site et puis dès l'année prochaine on
aimerait avoir une toute nouvelle forêt
des aigles à vous présenter donc ça
c'est notre gros projet de l'année 2024
il y aura aussi des événements
saisonniers qui sont prévus exactement
donc au fil des au fil des saisons
évidemment le brame du cerf événement à
ne pas manquer et qui qui a lieu tous
les ans et qui qui sera
reconduitage un peu en rédaction on en
voit nos journées recueillir il faut
revenir avec le brame du cerf
c'est vraiment l'événement à ne pas
manquer et puis on va participer aux
Nuits de la forêt et puis avec de
l'événementiel aussi en juillet et puis
effectivement aussi pour les vacances de
la Toussaint on va voir un événement
autour de la forêt et du cernunoz qui
est le cerf de la nature c'est ouvert
tous les jours c'est ouvert tous les
jours jusqu'au 5 novembre et donc les
horaires pour venir sur terre entre 10h
et 18h et puis des fois 19h selon les
les vacances scolaires et puis on était
forcément on préfère rester un peu plus
tard avec le beau temps et le soleil qui
est là et combien coûte l'entrée alors
16 euros pour les adultes et 13 euros
pour les enfants bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site de l'Espace
Rambouillet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci Camille singer d'être venu
reparler sur ce plateau responsable
développement et stratégie de l'espace
remoué mais vous restez aussi avec nous
pour la fin de cette émission on va
passer maintenant aux autres idées de
sortie c'est une traditionnelle
chronique que vous présentez et que vous
avez l'honneur de représenter à nouveau
après avoir absence Gabriel avec un
spectacle de danse on commence
aujourd'hui avec un spectacle de danse
avec un spectacle de danse un spectacle
de danse à l'occasion de la semaine
journal olympique et paralympique
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines se mobilise
elle présente à la verticale de soi
alors c'est un projet sur le thème de
l'inclusion où se mêle l'alliance de la
recherche et de la création artistique
le la représentation elle a lieu
vendredi soir c'est à 19h à Versailles
et elle sera suivie d'un échange après
le spectacle avec le public on reste sur
scène mais on change de registre on
reste sur scène cette fois avec Antoine
Duléry l'acteur et imitateur se produit
à Maurepas vendredi soir dans un seul
enseigne imitant tour à tour de Londres
De Niro Lucini ou encore Galabru cette
comédie elle rend hommage aux acteurs du
passé et ce d'aujourd'hui entre
souvenirsne et digression Antoine dulory
fait se croiser le réel et l'imaginaire
on interprétant à la fois des
personnages du théâtre du cinéma et
aussi de la chanson on va direction
Achères à présent avec un spectacle
étonnant original également un spectacle
mené par un duo sauta Salta et dont le
titre donne déjà le ton avec comme cet
étrange le dieu d'artiste à bord de sous
toutes ses formes celui qui fait rire
celui qui fait peur ou qui questionne
mais aussi le surréalisme des poètes le
charme de l'inconnu tout ça Grégory avec
humour en chanson et en musique je vous
propose qu'on regarde un extrait
[Musique]
Vienne le léopard
qui
ronronne
à me voir et viens de nulle part
la représentation et la lieu ce samedi à
11h et pour ce premier long week-end de
printemps vous nous parlez d'un salon du
côté de Rambouillet oui de samedi à
lundi la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet accueille accueille le salon
art et jardin pour sa troisième édition
alors au programme plus de 90 exposants
sont attendus des professionnels du
paysage des marées chez nous aussi des
artisans d'art et des artistes venus
rencontrer le grand public de quoi vous
donner peut-être des idées pour
l'aménagement la décoration des
extérieurs et même le jardinage pourquoi
pas bon un petit tour par l'Espace
Rambouillet on n'oublie pas d'aller
acheter son chocolat pour pas qu'est-ce
qu'il y a aussi une autre idée de sortie
qui vous attire Régine dans ce qui a été
dit le spectacle de danse le spectacle
de danse Camille nationale la Bergerie
Nationale pour le salon et Olivier une
petite idée de sortir alors je sais que
ça va être compliqué ensuite de Pâques
mais j'ai vu qu'il y avait de bons films
au cinéma pour les enfants et j'avoue
que j'ai envie d'aller au cinéma aussi
et vous Gabriel la sélection de votre
sélection s'il y a une idée de sortie à
en sortir je pense que le spectacle de
danse pour la semaine olympique et
paralympique plutôt intéressant original
c'est aussi ma sélection pour vos idées
de sortie merci en tout cas de nous
avoir présenté ces idées de sortie on va
poursuivre notre série mode à présent
sur TV 78 Mélissa c'est bien et styliste
emojiste Richebourg dans les Yvelines à
la fondée à sa propre marque la mode de
Mélissa et vous partage ses meilleurs
conseils pour savoir comment bien vous
habiller au quotidien ce soir elle vous
donne ces astuces pour savoir si un
vêtement vous va bien
bonjour je suis Mélissa sebir la
fondatrice de la mode de Mélissa et je
vous retrouve aujourd'hui pour vous
donner quelques astuces pour vous aider
à savoir si un vêtement vous convient
vraiment ou pas l'idée dans cette
chronique c'est de vous partager deux
astuces on va dire ça comme ça deux
points de vue en tout cas la forme et la
couleur et je vais commencer avec vous
par la couleur j'ai tendance à dire que
ça n'est pas vous qui choisissez le
vêtement mais c'est lui qui vous choisit
en fait il y a une astuce toute simple
pour savoir si une couleur vous va bien
ou pas il suffit de poser le vêtement
sous votre menton et en fait vous allez
voir tout de suite si votre visage
s'illumine vous voyez quand je mets du
rose parce que je sais que le rose est
une couleur qui qui illumine un petit
peu mon visage normalement vous voyez
déjà une différence
et si je viens mettre une chemise bleue
un peu plus foncée donc le Marine on
voit bien qu'il y a pas le même éclat
qu'avec le rose voilà c'est comme ça que
vous allez savoir si votre vêtement vous
convient réellement ou pas
[Musique]
quand on parle de mode on parle souvent
de silhouette de morphologie en aah y
voilà plein de lettres comme ça et en
fait ces idées là vous dirigent vers des
clichés pour choisir vos vêtements mais
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec ça
parce que pour moi on doit s'habiller
comme on a envie de s'habiller et c'est
pas parce qu'on est un ovale un 8 ou peu
importe qu'on ne peut pas porter de
vêtements amples ou au contraire qu'on
ne peut pas porter de vêtements serrés
près du corps c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je ne défends pas ces
silhouettes parce que justement la mode
doit être vecteur de de gaieté etc et
doit refléter votre personnalité ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
pas oublier donc ne suivez pas tous les
conseils qu'on peut trouver sur les
morphologies vous devez cacher vos bras
à 50 ans vous devez plus mettre de jupe
et tout non non non
habillez-vous comme vous en avez envie
et un conseil que je peux tout vous
donner c'est la robe portefeuille
donc la robe portefeuille c'est vraiment
une pièce qui va à toutes les
morphologies et qui va à toutes les
femmes ça je peux vous l'assurer c'est
parfait pour pour tout le monde si vous
avez un peu de poitrine le décolleté en
V va la mettre en valeur et si vous avez
beaucoup de poitrine ça va sublimer
juste ce qu'il faut sublimer si jamais
le décolleté vous dérange vous rajoutez
un caraco en dessous vraiment il y a
toujours des petits tips pour faire en
sorte que le vêtement vous convienne et
que vous soyez aussi confortable et à
l'aise dedans et en fait le fait d'avoir
une ceinture autour de la taille va vous
créer une silhouette et donc que vous en
ayez ou pas que vous soyez en H ou en X
vous pouvez porter ce type de robe et
après le côté portefeuille de la jupe va
voilà apporter de la légèreté va
dévoiler sans trop dévoiler vos jambes
et de ce fait ça convient à toutes les
femmes et pour conclure ce petit épisode
je voudrais juste vous demander de vous
assumer et de libérer votre créativité
au travers de vos vêtements vous êtes
très belle comme vous êtes
et montrez le
[Musique]
merci à Mélissa que l'on retrouve bien
sûr très prochainement sur tv78 vous
avez pris les bonnes notes des conseils
en plateau sur les couleurs parce que là
il s'agissait de vêtements féminins mais
en tout cas sur les couleurs vous pouvez
prendre le rose sortir ses yeux
maintenant donc c'est parti alors c'est
l'heure du quiz je sais que c'est un
événement un événement un rendez-vous
événement voilà j'ai grossi le trait qui
est très attendu dans le 7 8 on vous
challenge autour de la table les invités
bien sûr Camille et Olivier jouent avec
nous vous aussi derrière votre
télévision vous pouvez jouer bien sûr
avec moi à distance et ce soir on va
parler de Pâques alors d'habitude le
quiz est en lien avec les Yvelines là
exceptionnellement comme on a un
week-end prolongé en plus c'est le
premier du printemps on va élargir le
tir et parler de Pâques la tradition de
Pâques est aussi voire un peu ce qui se
passe au travers du monde est-ce que
vous êtes prêts vous êtes tous prêts je
lui ai demandé en régie à ce qu'on
prenne bien les scores en Platon on va
peut-être faire deux équipes on fait
L'Équipe TV 78 contre l'équipe invitée
team TV Sonic allez c'est parti on prend
bien les notes bien sûr en régie alors
la première question pourquoi parle-t-on
d'oeufs de Pâques d'où vient cette
dénomination à votre avis
de Pâques
alors je vais vous donner un petit
indice parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
rapport alors c'est je demande plus une
période historique d'où ça vient d'où ça
vient c'est de l'antiquité très bonne
réponse et un premier point inscrit par
la team invité à ma droite effectivement
très ancienne tradition qui est pas qui
remonte à la haute antiquité en Egypte
et à Rome on offrait déjà des œufs parce
qu'il était ils étaient les symboles de
renouveau et justement qu'on était aussi
au printemps alors Pâques vient du latin
Pasqua qui veut dire nourriture et de
pas cherer qui veut dire prêtre paître
pardon prêtre c'est autre chose
peut-être alors il y a l'idée de
transhumance on le sent bien et pas qui
est une fête bien sûr chrétienne qui est
célébrée le premier dimanche après la
pleine lune suivant le 21 mars un
premier point pour la team invité à ma
droite deuxième question qu'est-ce que
lister aigrel qu'on pratique aux USA et
notamment dans les jardins de la Maison
Blanche en quoi ça consiste Easter
eggroll dans le jardin alors on en est
pas sur cachés
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez une autre
possibilité une autre suggestion je
pense qu'on va quand même accorder le
point à gauche effectivement alors c'est
pas tout à fait un golf mais
effectivement il s'agit avec Gabriel
c'est un jeu alors déjà vous aviez
raison de faire rouler le plus loin
possible et le plus rapidement possible
un œuf dur avec une cuillère même le
président des États-Unis à l'occasion de
se prêter à cette tradition dans les
jardins de la maison blanche un partout
égalisation de la team TV 78 alors on va
partir du côté de la Hongrie alors en
Hongrie on s'habille en costume
traditionnel à l'occasion de Pâques et
les garçons font quelque chose avec les
filles mais quoi
question bizarre pardon
directement c'est une coutume à
l'occasion à l'occasion de Pâques qui
est le chocolat ça n'a pas de rapport
avec le chocolat bon c'est vrai que
c'est assez difficile pas de réponse je
vais vous donner la réponse alors les
garçons arrose les filles do à grands
coups de seau d'eau même pour ainsi dire
vous le voyez à l'image alors c'est une
vieille coutume qui remonte même avant
l'air chrétienne et qui était censé
garantir la fertilité des filles du
village toujours à partout entre les
deux équipes avec cette question après
cette question il n'y a pas eu de bonnes
réponses on part au Nicaragua à présent
voyage dans ce 7 fuite les catholiques
ne mangent pas de viande à pain ils
mangent de la viande mais une viande
particulière on va dire on va dire par
quoi justement on remplace la viande
traditionnelle quel est l'animal qui est
consommé à Pâques par les habitants du
Nicaragua
qui sont pas des poules
si c'est un animal pardon alors la
question disait on mange pas de viande
mais si c'est bien de la viande mais
c'est une viande un peu originale on va
dire
quelle espèce on peut trouver justement
en Amérique centrale Amérique latine un
oiseau non ce n'est pas un oiseau c'est
un on parle ici d'un félin
je m'embrouille les pinceaux un reptile
merci alors
je vous oriente mal bien on parle bien
d'un reptile pardon
c'est pas un crocodile un
iguane très bonne réponse qui est bien
un reptile et pas un félin pardon merci
merci à l'oreillette oui oui je vous ai
mal orienté je vous ai le mal orienté en
tout cas la team TV 78 qui prend le
point de l'avantage de points à 1 pour
TV 78 il y a notamment un donc c'est
bien de la viande d'iguane avec de
grandes ventes d'iguanes qui sont opérés
sur les marchés qui se monnaie environ 3
euros pièce allez une dernière question
pour peut-être tenter d'égaliser on est
déjà à la dernière question en Grèce que
mange-t-on à l'occasion de Pâques
il y a trois il y a il y a trois mecs
que l'on consomme à pas je demandais
d'en donner au moins un qu'est-ce qu'on
consomme qu'est qu'est-ce qu'on consomme
traditionnellement en Grèce
de nourriture c'est quelque chose qui va
dans l'eau non on est en rapport avec
l'agneau pascal qu'est-ce qu'on consomme
de l'agneau pascal voilà très très
précisément
alors 5 secondes une une partie du corps
de l'agneau pascal les pâtes non pas les
pâtes malheureusement non
malheureusement de la team TV 70 minutes
alors quelle est la bonne réponse et
bien en principe on consomme une
assiette de tripes tout simplement à
Pâques sur laquelle on peut rajouter le
cœur et le poumon de l'agneau pascal bon
appétit si vous apprêtez à passer à
table alors on le consomme plus
fréquemment à tout tous ces mets avec
ses tripes ce cœur et ce poumon d'agneau
dans une soupe qui est surnommée la
soupe myritza pardon si j'écorche au
niveau de la prononciation grecque en
tout cas c'est la tradition du côté de
la Grèce bravo la team TV sandwich et
Gabriel qui remporte ce quiz autour de
Pâques mais bravo tout de même à Camille
et Olivier qui ont bien tenté
de se frotter à ce quiz bientôt la fin
du 7 8 vous a prêté peut-être à partir
quelques jours pour en congé en province
au-delà de la région parisienne et qui
dit week-end prolongée à dit forcément
galère sur les routes quels sont les
prévisions sur les routes ce week-end
Gabriel et bien ce sera compliqué
Grégory dès demain Bison Futé voir rouge
dans le sens des départs en Île de
France c'est Orange sur une bonne partie
du territoire il est conseillé de
quitter au traverser la région avant 10h
les grands axes comme l'autoroute A6
sont à éviter entre 10h et 16h alors
samedi ça s'améliore légèrement ça
revient à l'orange mais ça risque d'être
perturbé si vous avez prévu de vous
rendre en Normandie ou en Bretagne donc
un conseil quitté ou traverser
l'Île-de-France après 17h et éviter les
autoroutes à 13 ou encore à 10 sachez
que dimanche le trafic sera normal dans
toute la France avant le retour des
complications lundi c'est rouge dans le
sens des retours de la région et surtout
la partie nord-ouest de la France alors
Bison Futé préconise de rejoindre le
territoire francilien avant 11h rester
informé sur le site de Bison Futé voilà
vous savez tout merci Gabriel on sait
tous sur sur ces prévisions dernier coup
d'oeil à présent à la météo de demain
[Musique]
et je le disais en début d'émission il
faudra encore attendre avant de revoir
un beau soleil dans les Yvelines ces
nuageux demain matin sur l'ensemble du
département 7 degrés dans les secteurs
de Versailles et Mantes-la-Jolie 8
degrés à Houdan 6 degrés à Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi de la pluie devrait se
joindre à la partie côté température
compter 13 degrés partout et dans les
Yvelines et pour vos prévisions météo du
week-end je vais laisser la main à
Thomas Fletcher notre Mr météo pas comme
les autres dans alors quoi de beau il se
penche sur une question épineuse ou
cachée les autres pack
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans votre météo du week-end alors quoi
de beau ce weekend sachez que déjà lundi
c'est férié c'est lundi de Pâques
c'est lundi de Pâques
il y a des œufs c'est la fête
normalement ce week-end il pleut pas à
part une pluie deux apparemment puis
deux d’œufs
le température elle remonte elle remonte
elle remonte petit un petit peu mais pas
trop non plus ok donc faut pas s'exciter
non plus on sort pas le maillot de bain
encore mais on va pas tarder quoi parce
que ça remonte mais pas trop non plus
donc c'est cool mais pas non plus hyper
cool quoi hop là
avec la sieste j'ai un petit jeu pour
votre week-end au repas de famille ça
marche super bien la grosse cloche sonne
la grosse cloche sonne la grosse cloche
sonne la grosse cloche sonne je
suis super fort et maintenant on va voir
si vous n'êtes pas c'est super dur et
puis on va voir du coup si vous n'êtes
pas coupable
on va voir si vous n'êtes pas pas cap
joyeuses pâques
est-ce que vous fêtez pas monsieur et
non je ne le fait plus bonjour il est
beau comme ça merci est-ce que vous
faites des packs par hasard
est-ce que vous faites pas je pense que
oui si vous êtes chocolatier
est-ce que vous faites des Pâques
est-ce que vous avez des techniques pour
cacher vos œufs vous oui
que dans le jardin il y avait il y avait
de quoi faire en fait c'était de prendre
beaucoup de très petits œufs là-dedans
là ouais dedans
vous cacheriez comment et où
il est bizarre votre costume
[Rires]
donc c'était facile à cacher dans le
jardin il faut nous montrer un peu cette
technique de professionnels faut visiter
ma boutique c'est là où je l'ai cache
alors là par exemple visible pour les
enfants c'est il faut que ce soit
visible mais pas visible voilà ok par
exemple dans le trou là le petit trou là
là donc dimanche vous le mettez là
je trouve qu'ils sont très très mal
cachés dans la boutique et vous mangez
quand même du chocolat le dimanche non
d'accord et joyeuses Pâques du coup
mais comment vous faites vous
réceptionner les cloches bah là il y en
a deux qui se présentent comme ça que je
viens de croiser dans la rue
non non mais c'était effectivement des
questions mais c'est des questions
primordiales
comme une bonjour bonjour bonjour
on cherche des œufs je sais pas si il y
en a dans le dans l'établissement
peut-être que je me mette à chercher
mais donc là ça aussi c'est du chocolat
ça aussi
tout est-ce qu'on peut faire avec du
chocolat bah plein de choses des robes
n'importe quoi c'est des costumes c'est
du chocolat là ça pourrait
ça
belle rencontre alors je le Précis
c'était pas du tout préparé c'est parce
que vous venez en plateau ce soir vous
l'avez rencontré tout à fait par hasard
météo
de mes voisins et voilà et on est parti
dans un délire sympa et c'était vraiment
trop bien il y avait Patrick à la caméra
lui le lui avec son costume voilà je lui
ai dit c'était pour Dan quoi c'était
Patrick la caméra mais c'est vrai
comment vous trouvez ce petit module
qu'on qu'on propose maintenant à noter
les spectateurs
avec plein de conseils pour aller cacher
mes œufs ce weekend donc c'est parfait
je vais essayer de mettre en pratique
des petits tips Thomas qui est en régie
actuellement que l'on salue bien sûr
notre Mr météo parce qu'il est aussi
monteur sur tv78 et qui technique
également Mister météo il a plusieurs
casquettes plusieurs cordes à son arc
Thomas merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous Gabriel merci
Régine merci Olivier et merci également
à notre invité Camille pardon voilà je
cherchais le prénom voilà c'est aussi ça
c'est les notions que Thomas m'a procuré
qui revient à la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivi dans ce 7 8
qui touche à sa fin je vous souhaite un
très bon week-end prolongé si vous avez
la chance d'en profiter le statut
revient mardi prochain à l'antenne
rendez-vous en direct à 18h d'ici là
portez-vous bien très belle soirée sur
TV 78
[Musique]